こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです
はい、というわけで皆さま
8月ももう終わりでございます
夏休みいかがだったでしょうか
大学を卒業してからバタバタと忙しかったんですけども、
夏休みの8月中はね、
静岡でなるべく動画を撮るようにさせていただいたので、
けっこう、こう、のんびり、
のんびりもしてないな
結構こう、時間をかけた動画をね。
なんこか...
何個か、ほんとに
ほんとに
なんか面白いかどうかは別として
なんかぁ...
面白いかどうかは別としてぇ！
僕がやりたいと思った動画を結構
僕がやりたいなと思った動画を結構できたと思っております
本当にいつも見てくださる皆さまありがとうございます
今回なんですけども 僕は普段ですねしょーもない動画をはじめしゃちょー2というサブチャンネルで出してるんですけども
ガチでやってる動画の中でも たまにこれはねーなと思ってる動画もあるんですよ
僕はイメージとしては サブチャンネルはひたすら
割と手の込んだ動画をサブチャンネルを出すのはあんまりしたくないので 行き場のない動画ができるんです
別にあげてもいいんだけどね プライド的にこれはあげたくないなという動画 いわゆるNG動画とかね
実はこんなこともやってたよっていう動画が何個かありますので
では早速みていきましょう はい！
一斉に100人でベイブレードを打つという流れでございます
会場）おー！
会場）3、2、1、GO！
行きます！
行くぜ！
わぁあああー！
♪パンパンパンパン♪
♪パン♪
もう大丈夫？
うおぉぉぉぉー！
私は思ってしまった 果たしてこのノート1冊を単語で全部埋めるのには だいたいどれくらいの時間がかかるのか
今回はこちらを検証していきたいと思います
弟）へっへっへ
はじめ）笑ってるわ
辛いものだということは知ってるよ だがそれを乗り越えないと未来はない
いくぞー！
はい これはほんまにしまってやろう
弟）よし やっていくぞー！
みんな ちゃんと 睡眠 とってますか？
というわけで 今日は PDS株式会社のダンテの家に来ております
というわけでいかがだったでしょうか NG集でございます
動画のデータ消しちゃったんですが 実は発汗作用のあるお風呂のバスソルト  すごく汗かくやつ
あれを日本中に売ってるのを全部集めて 風呂場にたたきこんで混ぜて 一番汗のかくダイエットできるお風呂を作ってみたという動画があるんですけど
動画データはないです なかったですけど 本当にやって ただただ汗が出る動画で特におもしろくなかったのでNGになりました
学生のみなさん！ 学校始まりますけども また暇な時ゆるーくはじめしゃちょーの動画でも見てください
じゃあな　じゃあな
（効果音）